on may 7th 1902 on the island of
Martinique the town drunk and
troublemaker got thrown into prison it
was the luckiest day of his life
CPR on Martinique was at the time known
as the Paris of the Caribbean it had a
big population of over 30,000 people and
was a cultural hub lugar sabores and he
was a local he was a drunk and he spent
a lot of time in prison Martinique is
home to Mount Peleg one of the most
active volcanoes in the world and the
day after he went into that prison cell
Mount Pele exploded in the weeks before
lugar so Burris was thrown into prison
the volcano on the island of Martinique
was showing signs of volcanic activity
although people knew that something was
gonna happen without modern Volcanology
they didn't have a really good sense of
how big or how dangerous the threat was
thousands of people left the countryside
and came to the city of st. Pierre
because they thought it would be safer
there that was a terrible mistake on May
8th the volcano erupted and in an
instant thirty thousand people were dead
a pressure wave a superheated pressure
wave of over a thousand degrees
flattened every single building the air
was replaced with superheated noxious
gases anyone who was you know unlucky
enough to be outside was instantly
burned to death those who were in
shelter found themselves choking as
their their lungs were literally burned
from the inside out there was really no
escape except for one person
lugar so Boris the cell he was in had
been built as a armoury as a place to
store ammunition so it had been built
within
we thick walls and it so happened that
the only openings in it faced away from
the eruption even so super hot air began
to force its way underneath the door and
as his cell heated to incredibly high
temperatures he was forced to strip
naked push his his clothes underneath
the door and he peed on the clothes just
to try and keep the hot air from
entering he was still badly badly burned
and he wasn't found until four days
later when rescuers heard his cries and
here's the interesting thing there are
suspicions because he was put into
solitary confinement and he may have
been in jail for something as serious as
murder but we'll never know because in
that one moment the entire town every
record of his wrongdoings were wiped off
the face of the earth this story was so
amazing so outlandish that he was
offered a contract by Barnum & Bailey to
travel the country as the man who
survived doomsday so he spent the next
years of his life presented as this this
kind of historical freak show this
incredible occasion of survival against
all odds so well the eruption of Mount
Pele may have meant doomsday for all of
saint-pierre for lugar sabores it was a
kind of salvation to subscribe click
here and to see more videos click here